[Musique]
nous avons dit sioniste dupond moretti
sur deux sujets le sujet de la relation
et des liens entre la justice et les
élus locaux et notamment les maires qui
sont officiers de police judiciaire qui
doivent rendre compte à leurs
populations des actes et qui se sont
produits chez eux et puis nous voulions
aussi avoir connaissance du bilan des
sanctions qui ont été données par la
justice suite aux plaintes déposées pour
agression d'élus ces derniers mois
venait en tête un chiffre en pourcentage
une évolution de plus de 47% des
agressions en direction des élus qu'il
s'agit de parlementaires de mer ou
d'adjoint toute forme d'agression soient
physiques ou verbales ou ou de menace
donc une progression extrêmement forte
et extrêmement élevé sur lequel ont
effectivement il était intéressant
d'entendre le garde des sceaux le monde
des élus locaux et le monde d'injustice
sont deux mondes qui s'ignorent parce
qu'on peut considérer que chacun a sa
fonction et dans son univers et
accomplit son métier très bien or force
est de constater quand on est élu local
ou même citoyen que il doit y avoir un
lien
entre le maire et la justice comme
aujourd'hui on a une collaboration très
efficace entre la gendarmerie et l'élu
cette loi engagement et proximité
préconise des rencontres avec le
procureur procureur de la république où
je dirais c'est de différents
intervenants à ses côtés mais permet
ainsi parce que c'était une forte
demande aussi de la part des élus de
faire connaître là la particularité de
leur commune de leur territoire et
réciproquement on va dire niveau de
l'injustice bien que les élus
connaissent mieux plus encore les
capacités d'agir d'action les
interlocuteurs sur leur territoire pour
pouvoir faire ce lien lorsqu'il ya
notamment des agressions des actes
d'incivilité qui sont eux aussi
malheureusement en très forte
augmentation dans les communes
[Musique]